a lot of times people ask the question
why are you rehabbing a squirrel it's a
rodent there's tons of them what's one
less well squirrels play an important
part in the whole ecosystem they are a
prey animals so they help feed a lot of
the other animals that are here and they
help with propagation of different types
of plants because they bury seeds and
and nuts it's an important life it's not
a decision that I like to make to
euthanize an animal just because they
are a squirrel or a rabbit they have
every right just like people have every
right to live here and to be a part of
nature some of the many ways that
squirrels end up here are due to they're
either found on the ground they're found
by pets people cut down trees and so the
nest falls down on the ground and so
they come into us and we assess them
here and then if they're really small we
will feed them formula with a syringe
and we care for them by toileting them
because they're unable to toilet
themselves and then we move them through
the phases in different size cages and
offering them different foods and in the
end we put them outside where they learn
to be a squirrel outside and when we
come in and feed here we don't talk to
any of them because we're trying to get
them back from between it into the wild
and then after about a week outside we
go ahead and release them back into the
wild
right now we have a little over a
hundred and ten squirrels here on
property all the squirrels that we have
here are called fox squirrels we do have
I think one melanistic squirrel meaning
that it is a fox squirrel but it's all
black and that is just a genetic thing
that happens one in every 100 verse
we named squirrels here because it's
easier for us to identify them
that's noodle hi noodle to go by a
number a number like 1 2 3 really
doesn't tell me much about the animal
but if the animal is named George I know
who George is and especially if he has
any issues all someone has to do is
mention hey George is doing much better
today or George's not doing better today
it's much easier for all of us to really
know the animals in the facility
antibiotics pain meds for a week and
then we'll put her down recheck one week
okay sounds good these guys require a
lot of time a lot of skill they require
hours and hours of work and so it's a
true dedication so sometimes for me I
feel like I'm running out of energy but
all I got to do is take a look at one of
these cuties and I'm ready to go again
[Music]
[Music]
Oh